hey what is up guys my name is Archana
welcome to episode 24 of three game
programming in Java all right it's
extremely hot right now this is what we
have by the way last time we had a
buttons that did not work but otherwise
we had a nice little frame a launcher
and we had buttons which is a which is
always awesome what was it saying yeah
yeah it's really hot right now like it's
I'm sitting here it's like 35 degrees
which is like I don't know like almost
100 degrees Fahrenheit I think 35
degrees Celsius it's that's really hot
right now I'll probably go down on the
beach
but um but now first you know if you
guys I'm gonna be doing this uh this
this thing alright
this game okay sort out the deal that I
made with you last time was you know
I'll sort of I'll do this stuff last
time where I sort of make buttons and
then this time we're gonna move on to
actually making age of these buttons
work so let's take a look at how we're
gonna do that it's actually really
simple
so yeah first of all let's actually move
launched oh I was thinking about this I
just then let's move launch her into our
into a new package it'll call GUI and
it's all sort of me all about I'd call
it menu but well my just call it a
launcher actually and I'll call it GUI
all right and let's just mouse over this
and move the launcher into into a new
package and display is gonna fail
because of that so let's go down and fix
that and go and actually import launch
one what all right cool back to the
launcher what's close wrong game as well
but I know we don't need that so I don't
know how you guys if you guys know how
to do this before because there are I
think there's like a few different ways
to actually sort of add action listeners
to our two DUIs this is by far the
easiest way in my opinion of course I've
I've done a few different ways and this
is probably the easiest so all we need
to do is say okay we want to add an
action listener for the play button how
do we do that so let's just come down
here and go play dot add action listener
and then what we have to do is as the
parameter we have to put new action
listener
and it's actually like I'm it's actually
like a method in itself so we need to do
this and put a little thing at the end
and also you'll see that it was
important first of all you'll see that
it actually implements it needs to
implement a particular method called
action performed so public void action
performed and it's like action event a
and that's that'll let's just and for
that that should I get rid of all errors
there we go alright so at first you guys
might be like whoa dude what is this
waxed syntax I've never seen this before
and of course a lot of you I know I've
already already saying what are you
kidding dude of course I know well that
is cool but some people probably don't
sew it and it might look really strange
to you but see it's not all it is is
basically this right so we've got our
new action listener we need to sort of
open that and then we close it and then
all we have left is we sort of need to
we've opened our action listener thing
right we've opened we've we've implement
we've sort of we've ran this method
called add action listener and it has
obviously parentheses for the parameters
so and the parameter the parameters are
held between two parentheses or two
button or we call circular brackets i
call them parentheses i think that's
actually what they're called and
obviously we need to end that and you
can see that it ends right over here and
after we put a semicolon as usual so all
it is is it's just this that i've
highlighted right here is the parameter
that's all i'm just when i hit control
shift f2 to move that back into a
position it'll reformat reformat it for
you okay so i'm gonna take a drink right
now cuz it's really hot even with the
air conditioner i don't really have one
in my room but anyway in this room yeah
so we've done that now that's awesome so
basically what we've done is we've said
when you hit play do whatever is in here
so action perform do whatever's in here
so let's just let's just print a line
just to check if it's working system but
how the print line
and we'll um we'll just say play all
right so let's run it make sure in
console OOP arrow let's run it and hit
play and look at that right here in the
console play works so play is working
out a little bit little me kidding quit
as if as if that works let's add an
action listener one two three four each
of the other ones so options and I am
actually taking too long right now five
minutes I don't have that much time all
right
um I'm gonna okay this here's the deal
by the way I haven't actually coded this
before so I hope I don't actually make
any errors but um yeah I haven't had
time to actually wrote like letting on
guess rehearse this tutorial so I yes
let's just check if all these are
working and again that explanation mark
if you don't put it it won't work so
just to make sure that you do
I'm kidding by the way if you if you
thought that that was serious and you
guys need a need a rehearse your Java
because I'm I'm not serious all right
so play options help quit that all works
fantastic all right next up you want to
you want to actually make quit quit the
game so just go assistant or exit
actually I got a question the other day
about this status thing what does it
mean all right it's it's completely
irrelevant to the way that system
actually quits all right that's that's
important that you understand that it's
irrelevant okay you always put zero okay
you can put whatever you like zero is
meant to indicate you know that it's
normal
exit now if you were really serious it's
actually a convention to put a number
there like one if the exited thing if
the status was not was abnormal so in
other words I guess we should put if we
were really serious again we'd put
systems on exit here if it if it can't
start the thread we put this to one now
I'm just gonna leave it as one but that
means that is it the system closed but
it wasn't supposed to close the program
okay something went wrong so in other
words an exception was generated all
right so that's answering your question
but um when we hit quit we expected to
close so we just put zero so now if we
hit quit you'll say the determinates
fantastic
all right so
let's get started into actually creating
it I guess the next thing I don't know
if we'll have time for help
we'll definitely have time to have time
to yeah I really can't talk today I have
time for play so for play let's first of
all that's pretty simple actually do we
have wrong game right here yeah okay all
right we just need to run game basically
so new run game all right
I bought that should we move on game
into GA what he isn't white no why is
this just no all right no I want to copy
that
all right um juju wise oh wait what why
do we have two of the same packages all
right copy it is done I don't know
what's going on what is going on right
under that okay I I don't know let's
call that so let's import our own game
okay whatever so if we had play now
you'll see that it runs again now you
guys might be like okay that's awesome
it works but if you actually move this
window you'll see wha wha this didn't
close right sorry and actually if we
close either of them you'll see that it
uh it actually terminates the program
that's fine but um what we need to do
first is say that let's just dispose so
again sure I don't I don't need to
explain this to you guys but if you if
we're sending a frame we don't need it
you know dispose it as part of the
jframe class so once once we hit that if
you pay attention to this as well hit
play there's no why there's nothing
behind it so that is that's cool that's
lovely
alright that's how you get rid of frames
now options is actually off the top of
my head it's gonna be pretty hard to
actually do not not hard just it'll take
a while so I'm not gonna I'm really
gonna sort of rush through this because
I don't have time and I'd get back to
her to studying so um
another drink of water um so what we
have to do now is basically launch a new
dialogue basically my idea for options
is when when we actually hit options
what's gonna happen is it's gonna open
it's gonna close this window it's gonna
open another much bigger window and I'll
have options for like I don't know
resolution fullscreen ah you know
anything basically
but because I'll leave that sort of up
to you all I'm gonna implement his
resolution for you guys so I'll show you
guys on how to how to change the
resolution so that when you hit play it
launches at that selected resolution so
our idea at the moment is when we hit
options we want to open a bigger
dialogue with like an OK button to
return back to this menu and a little
like a drop-down box with multiple
options to select the resolution again
that's that's sort of the deal all right
so the way we're gonna do that is
actually let's just okay so when we hit
the new when we hit options button we
want to sort of make a new clip we want
to open a new window will call it
options so again I'm gonna be coding
pretty fast here sir they're with me
it's create a new class options are
created in the GUI package and we're
actually gonna make it extends our
launcher all right sorry this is very
simple extent launcher means that it's
gonna basically inherit everything here
now I'll talk a bit about permissions
and stuff like that but for the most
part it's fine all right so in other
words what we want to do is we want to
make a constructor for this class and
what we're gonna do is type super
alright now the thing with that is sorry
make sure you call it options my bad
another thing with that is super means
that it's basically gonna do we've I
think have we used it before I swear we
have and screen yeah super here we go we
used it what that's gonna do is
basically um it's gonna when we hit
options it's gonna run whatever is in
the constructor now there are certain
things at the moment that we don't want
to run first of all we sort of we want
to we want to create all this but for
example we don't want the title to be
mine front launcher now the great thing
about this actually let me just show you
what adults we had options is just gonna
make another dialog it's gonna keep
doing that and you can see how many
everyone right here so that's the deal
at the moment but the
one is that when we hit super you know
it's gonna make a new instance I guess
of the closeted extends which is
launcher and this is the constructor so
there's a few things that we don't want
to do we want to sort of override them
now the great thing is if we set title
again it's gonna actually take this
title as the higher priority title so in
other words it's gonna override it and
you could even put over right over was
it override I don't know that's love to
you um well technically you put it here
actually oh man okay you put it in a in
a method like public void main I don't
know position of call domain anyway what
is going on
must over yeah okay basically override
is just like a comment okay and don't it
doesn't do anything actually you'll see
you'll see me making over I think a
minute if you go into lot launcher and
say let's add another action listen if I
play this what listen all right you'll
see that if I add the unemployment to
method you say that it got the override
thing there don't worry about that just
delete it it doesn't do anything okay
that's vital I think I got another
question like that on Twitter that I I
never good never got to answer but um
yeah override it is completely
meaningless it's the same thing as a
comment alright anyway back to this
let's just set the title to I don't know
just options my front launcher I've no I
don't have time to think of creative
title say we had options you'll see that
it changed options let's also set the
size to new dimension and we'll probably
describe width and height and again
width and height you might be like hang
on isn't it going to inherit with an
high from launcher and nope not because
with an how to both private again that's
important private means that it can only
be using this class you guys should know
that so private width also that equal to
540 I guess and height we might look
like 440
and that's looking good all right what
else we need to do we need to set
actually I'll show I'll demonstrate it
to you guys first and of course I'm an
alien forgot forgot to actually put the
data type there so there are integers so
int actually let's go fifties 55450 all
right so when we what is the R now what
no if we had options you'll see that it
makes a big one now a few problems first
of all our buttons are still freaking
here that's a problem second of all
you'll see that what act what happens is
when we hit options it actually doesn't
it just expands the frame it doesn't put
it into the into the middle that's fine
we just need to go set location relative
to you know no again
and the other thing there the other
problem that we have at the moment is
the button problem we don't want these
buttons here now very simple let us go
in here and say that if ID equals zero
let's let's draw buttons so I only fight
a equals your own ID we'll set the end
ID over here alright so that when we
actually launch it in display the ID is
zero now over here when we when we go
super set the ID to one so will that
what that will do is say it won't
actually draw it here but when we launch
it it will completely door all the
buttons as usual so we've gone rid of
the buttons effectively because this
like this I called it ID because that's
like the menu idea okay we'll make we'll
make you know this ID 0 this ID 1 32 and
that's not really a menu oh wow I'm so
thirsty what time are we out for this is
royal 15 minutes well alright alright
alright alright
I've got a code faster I guess alright
so what we want to do is that's pretty
much it let's make another method called
row button so because we actually want
to draw different buttons and actually
I'm gonna call it we can call it row
buttons or whatever you like and let's
just create that method obviously oh oh
no I did not want to do that
what I wanted to do rather is create a
method
private avoid chiral buttons okay and
we're basically gonna do the same thing
here so let's make a private jbutton and
we'll call it okay
and we'll also make a rectangle and call
it R okay like we always did last time
like we always said last time that
something it's not like we did last time
rather like like we did once last time
let's and put the two things control
shift or you guys know the drill
and again we're just gonna set okay call
to new J button and put the parameters
okay pretty simple and all I'm gonna do
here is also make the rectangle but when
I'm as I make the rectangle what I'm
gonna do is set let's set the location
actually we want the OK button to sort
of be in the bottom left corner so let's
maybe said it's like width minus
like 100 so it's like 100 away from that
cuz again it'll be sort of long so 100
and we'll set the height to like minus
70 I'm you don't need you don't need the
brackets there that's just me trying to
make it look better um and we'll go
button width because we want to be one
with and we'll go button height because
we want them to be the same so we're
sort of inheriting them from and I'm
probably did not set them to public to
whatever all right
here's little new thing for you guys
there's you I'm sure that all of you
know of public and private all right you
guys know what that is now there's
actually one more that you guys probably
would have heard of but it's called
protected now what is protected they're
protected and lost set button harder
protected protected means that this
variable is visible in every in this
class in this entire class and in every
class which extends this class so
because options extends launcher button
hot button within button height is
visible all right so if we only want to
make it across classes that extends this
class then we use protected all right
again I could have set it to public
because we don't use it in any other way
but in any other class but
you know it's better to set it to
protected because we only needed in
these classes alright so um let's
actually that button is gonna be huge
let's actually just subtract like ten
from the height so that it's sort of
like that I'm so not that fat of a
button options all right we didn't draw
them do we know we didn't win all right
so let's set the bounds to be or are
okay and finally let's add to the window
we'll add a Norris illusion table so
that okay really
why don't I make everything private so
the J panel we want to be protected as
well hip thing okay and options and now
we have this thing you'll also notice
that this frame didn't disappear it's
all right now we have an OK button let's
go back into here and make sure that we
actually um again with the weight of
spores so that we get rid of that frame
you can say hit OK I say that as if it's
supposed to do something let's go back
to here and actually just add a ok don't
add actionless not new actionlistener I
should just copy and paste the code
really listener is really hard to
actually spell properly I'm telling you
and again let's just add the important
of all
then add the unimplemented methods
awesome all right let's go back to our
launcher so launcher again I'd a zero
and um this bar is honestly so let's
check if that if that little menu loop
works options or k options you're okay
options okay yeah seems to work seems to
work pretty well all right cool now
that's actually looking pretty good more
19 minutes what we want to do is sort of
make like a drop-down menu where you can
select your resolution now that's
actually very simple to do okay
there's something there's something
called choice so let's make that pub
private rather private choice
we'll call it resolution
equals new choice all right and I'll
support choice the choice is a drop down
like menu box thing Java it's called
choice there's also one called J select
but I don't know what it's called
it doesn't really old one as well choice
is like the good one that you want to
use basically for our for everything so
let's go down here and you go resolution
equals no donor don't actually need to
do that let's make a new rectangular
call it our resolution and just for our
dashing purposes let's make this down
here and make sure you call this our
resolution there yeah all right cool
so resolution equals or reds or Lucian
could've just called it res but I want
to be precise so that equals new
rectangle and again I guess we'll just
set it to like 50 80 did they again
these are just the coordinates so they
just want the top of my head and we'll
make the width of it 80 and we'll make
the high 25 because drop-down boxes are
usually pretty wide and not very high
and now we actually want to add in all
that any our menu items and all you do
is you get the yet this object the
object the choice object called
resolution in our case and we've got to
add and you can see pop-up menu right
here and they're basically strength so
first resolution we might have is 640 by
480 actually yeah okay and we'll just
make make two more we'll make this 1024
by 768 and this one 800 by 600 all right
no problem and resolution dot yeah I
think there's also a way to yep let's
select okay we select light in position
like one we'll see if this works I don't
know if it was Ivan Ivan actually tried
this before I have an actor
basically what I'm doing with this is
I'm making the default selected to
actually be the second option and we
don't need any more resolution do we
Nora that's it now we're just need to
add it to our window let's say this
works odd window add resolution all
right cool options I also might worked
cool
this didn't like that for some reason oh
we didn't set the balance resolution dot
sets bounds to our rectangle all right
Iran options cool so yeah awesome so I
did it did actually slide this one as
the default one so now we've got we've
got a few different resolutions that we
can actually select which is cool so say
we select this one and here okay well
what we want to happen is when we hit
play we want to actually run this game
at that selector resolution so how do we
do that it's actually quite simple all
right first of all we need some way to
actually set the resolution now you
can't change the resolution in-game and
that's the same case for like any game I
don't know I don't know if someone's
some wise guy with C++ is gonna come in
and say sooo blue world can do that nor
okay any programming language if you
want to change the resolution of that
application you need to restart it
that's that's well that's it's the same
for everything so we need to actually
restart our game now the benefit of
doing it through a launcher is we
haven't started our game yet the game
only runs when we hit play so before we
hit play we can set resolution to
whatever we want it to be so first of
all I'm just gonna go over here and
we've got our public static final in
width and height now we want to remove
them completely all right because we're
not using them anymore what we want to
do is just create public and width and
we'll set that equal to 800 again you
only pretty much use cap it's a
convention again obviously doesn't
matter but you only use full capital
letters if you use final so if it's a
constant alright that's just a
convention you can actually it is
possible to do this this will not cause
errors but it's just convention to
name all your constants with capital
letters alright with isn't a constant at
the moment cuz we've changed it and
public we don't even need static public
heights equals 600 all right that's sort
of the default thing now we need to
actually create two methods which
actually sort of return a particular
value so in other words we want to say
that if if our selected option here is
the third option which is this
resolution
let's return that particular width and
height so how do we do that again I'm
really thirsty today it is like 32 or
whatever outside so I guess that's uh
that's normal um okay cool so the way we
do that is um let's let's just create
two sort of methods actually before I do
that let's create a static variable
we'll make it public static and we'll
call a selection int selection and we'll
set it equal to zero to begin with all
right what we want to do here is when we
actually select something what we want
to do is we want to actually sort of get
that number so in other words if we run
this this the first option is zero the
second option is one the third option is
two and so on so forth so we want to
sort of get the selection index and
that's actually what it's called so all
we want to do is before we actually
display before we launch the new
launcher when we hit OK
let's set the selection variable equal
to resolution dot get selected item not
item index item is actually the string
so in other words we'd have to return
that or return that or return that but
it's easier to do it with a with an
integer so yeah and that will actually
set that equal to what it needs to be
equal to so let's also just make sure
the worst by printing this laid out
selection and make sure you're on the
console so if we select this one hit OK
it should return one as a dead if was
like if we select the first one and hit
OK should return zero say it did and
finally the third one should return -
and it did awesome cool so that works so
now let's create a method so
public public and it won't be void avoid
means it doesn't return anything we
actually want to return a value from it
so we want to return an integer so
public int and we'll just call it a
width or something we'll call it get
game with now this is important all
right don't call it get with the problem
would get with is the get width is
actually a method in canvas and we don't
really want to access that because if we
do and we put get with somewhere if you
see that for example was with somewhere
here with like there's width right here
if we actually put get with what its
gonna do is if we hold our button over
it's as you can see it's actually gonna
get with in component all right so you
can see that it's actually it's doing
it's not getting our width is getting
this width now that's kind of vital so
don't call it get with let's just call
get game with call whatever you like
that hasn't been taken because it's full
of white errors and obviously we need to
return a value but before we do that
let's say that if our selection equals
zero or our selection equals negative
one and this isn't actually that
important but it sort of is because this
will stop errors maybe for some reason
our selection will equal null and if it
does we want to we want to not crash
let's set that equal to negative one
let's set our width equal to 800 now it
already is on 800 but in case we sort of
set it equal to 600 and then change it
later set it equal to 800 if our
selection equals one then we want to
actually no that's wrong this should be
600 in it cuz I'll al 0 selection is 640
all right then in other words let's move
this to here as well so this is like the
default one set it equal to 800 and if
selection equals two then let's add our
width equal to 1024 right and at the end
finally let's return with
again this should be self-explanatory
basically what it's doing is it's
checking for any of these and finally
it's returning whatever there's equals
so when we want to access get game with
that variable then it it sets us to one
of these pretty self-explanatory let's
just copy and paste this because I don't
have time and we'll do the same thing
for height so get game height and again
this will just be height height is gonna
a call 480 well what am i doing
480 well how did I type 640 without even
warning - that was weird I swear I hit
for Eddie there anyway Heights well so
height equals was a her 600 and a 7/16
and I'm pretty sure that's right
actually let me just check what is a
thousand 24 times 3/4 yeah seven six
that all right cool
so return height well once the return
height all right cool
so now we want to actually read
basically let's search for width
everywhere
let's ripple and again you can see that
it hasn't actually saying we've actually
delivered that variable that variable
but it hasn't it is still resolving to a
variable why because of you can see that
if we hold nothing over whether it's
actually it's it's going to image
observer it's referring to a completely
different variable now so let's change
this to get width
sorry my bad get game with and make sure
that you do that for every whip thing
you see and same for height
get game height get game height and the
same thing there's stuff up here as well
I think isn't yeah here here it is so
this needs to be get game with same with
here and this needs to get we get game
height up all right and that should work
all right so let's actually check that
out and make sure it works most of this
to 640 by 480 and hit play oh that did
not work okay cool let's go into run
game actually and make sure that this
sort of works let's get rid of path
and let's actually go frame dot set size
and we'll set size equal to display dot
let's let's go back into this play
didn't I make these static public static
let's make them static we could make
these methods static actually yeah let's
do that
but then yeah we'll make all these
static as well done all right that
should work so make these static as well
and let's set this to display yet width
yeah game with 4k forgetting get game
with and this one true display don't get
game height all right awesome and let's
see if that works and don't forget the
comma all right run a play okay awesome
so okay first of all that's at 640 by
480 so it's defaulting to 640 by 480 for
some reason hit options let's select
that one
you see we're big and we're at low frame
rates now cuz alright 30 and yeah so you
can see how that's it obviously 1024 by
768 and a her percentage should be fine
all right cool the thing is though that
if we run the game straight away it's
actually running at a 640 by 480 which
isn't exactly ideal so let's see if we
can if we can fix that it's because it's
selecting this one and first of all
let's just get rid of this as well we
don't know planta line yeah that's a bit
of a problem all right
so it's defaulting to 640 by 480
probably because we sort of did this
because what we could physically swish
them around but it's alright well fixed
we'll probably fix it next time because
next time and that's the end of this
tutorial by the way 33 minutes while I
gotta get back to work next time what
we'll do is you can see that every time
we launch this it's going to default
back to that original one it's not going
to go and you can see how fast we're
running here really nice and smooth at
this resolution but um yeah next time
what we'll do first of all is we'll add
a help thing and also what we'll do is
we'll actually have when we hit okay
we'll actually make this value get
written to disk so it'll make a it'll
make like a notepad file it'll make like
a text file which has I don't know
something like width equals 800 and
height equals 600 so that every time we
launch the game we don't need to read
it'll sort of it'll remember it'll save
our preferences sort of into a text file
and so yeah so I don't know how many of
you guys know how to write data to an
actual text file on a hard drive but if
you don't then great we'll do that next
time
so yeah I remember to hit that like
button and I'll see you guys next week
later